[Música]
dos días continuos han durado los
combates en la región rusa de belgorot
es la primera vez desde que comenzó la
guerra en Ucrania que en Rusia hay un
enfrentamiento que dura más de un día y
hay versiones encontradas de un lado el
kremlin culpa a saboteadores ucranianos
pero se desligó de los hechos y afirma
que son ataques realizados por rusos
concretamente por grupos de extrema
derecha como la legión libertad de Rusia
y el cuerpo de voluntarios rusos o rbc
por sus siglas en inglés puede cambiar
el rumbo de la guerra esta clase de
incursiones en suelo ruso antes de
responder esta pregunta con nuestros
panelistas del debate veamos De qué
lugar estamos hablando belgorot es una
región que limita con Ucrania y está
ubicada en el suroeste de Rusia tanto el
gobernador regional como el comité de
investigación de Rusia alegan que hubo
ataques concretamente en la localidad de
greyboron y afirman incluso que allí
derribaron drones ucranianos sin embargo
hubo bombardeos con morteros y
artillería según Moscú que afectaron
edificios residenciales y
administrativos incluso Rusia señala que
hubo doce civiles heridos y que una
adulta mayor falleció pero el asesor de
la presidencia ucraniana micaylo
podoliac niega que aquí Efe esté
involucrado escuchemos
el único motor político en un país
totalitario de tornillos apretados es
siempre un movimiento guerrillero armado
Ucrania observa con interés los
acontecimientos en la región de belgorot
en Rusia y estudia la situación pero no
tiene nada que ver como saben los
tanques se venden en cualquier tienda
militar rusa y los grupos guerrilleros
clandestinos están compuestos por
ciudadanos rusos
pero aunque Ucrania niega Cualquier
relación con estos grupos tanto el rbc
como legión libertad de Rusia han
afirmado que tienen el respaldo del
ejército ucraniano y que de otra forma
No hubieran podido hacer estos ataques
escuchemos el pronunciamiento que
hicieron luego de lo que ocurrió en
belgorota
la situación en belgoroda ha estado
sucediendo durante algún tiempo y como
vemos llama mucho la atención por lo
tanto Rusia se verá obligada a traer
refuerzos de otras partes de la línea
del frente
en unidades de la línea del frente
ucraniana facilitará las cosas para
Ucrania para avanzar en la
contraofensiva y liberar su territorio
este es uno de los objetivos tácticos
estamos Unidos con Ucrania en nuestra
lucha contra la agresión de Putin los
ucranianos están liberando sus tierras y
nosotros empezamos a liberar las
nuestras
por su parte Rusia replicó que mató a 70
nacionalistas ucranianos y desplegaron
una operación antiterrorista que implica
controles fronterizos en la región
verificación de documentos y vigilancia
de las comunicaciones
en el curso de la operación
antiterrorista a los regimientos
nacionalistas fueron bloqueados y
aplastados por la Aviación la artillería
y las acciones activas de los
regimientos de protección fronteriza del
distrito militar occidental los
nacionalistas restantes fueron
expulsados al territorio de Ucrania
Donde fueron bombardeados hasta su total
liquidación fueron liquidados más de 70
terroristas ucranianos destruidos cuatro
vehículos blindados y cinco camiones
para conversar sobre lo que ocurrió en
belgorod nos acompaña Román Ortiz
analista de seguridad y defensa del
centro de seguridad Internacional de la
universidad Francisco de Victoria y
quien nos acompaña desde Washington y
desde Buenos Aires se conecta Juan
Battle m directora académico del Consejo
argentino para las relaciones
internacionales a ellos bienvenidos y a
ustedes nuestros televidentes les
recuerdo que también hacen parte de este
debate pueden dejar sus comentarios y
preguntas en Twitter Facebook e
Instagram donde estamos como arroba
franz24-raya al piso e s pueden comentar
con la etiqueta numeral el debate f-24 y
a mí me encuentran como arroba maríacle
Aguirre no olviden que todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y TuneIn
Ahora sí para comenzar le quiero primero
que todo dar la bienvenida a Román
Gracias por estar con nosotros y
cuéntenos qué es lo que verdaderamente
está ocurriendo en belgorot o por lo
menos hasta donde conocemos
Muchas gracias Bueno yo yo creo que lo
que estamos viendo básicamente es la
combinación de dos cuestiones primero
hay una serie de grupos de oposición
emergentes en Rusia a algunos de ellos
parece que han tomado las armas Por otra
parte Ucrania está dándoles apoyo a
estos grupos
Y de alguna manera en ese sentido está
reproduciendo algo que ya sufrió ella
misma en el 2014 cuando Rusia
creó artificialmente en este caso
probablemente los grupos son más
Genuinos que el caso de los grupos
aprorusos de Ucrania pero en el 2014
Rusia creó unas milicias prorrusas en el
este de Ucrania y las apoyó desde y las
apoyó sistemáticamente en su
confrontación contra el gobierno
ucraniano ahora que estamos viendo Es de
alguna manera la vuelta de las tornas
verdad es Ucrania quien está respaldando
la oposición Armada rusa Más allá de
esto el objetivo de Ucrania creo que es
claro se trata de de alguna manera
extender el frente hacer que Rusia tenga
que guarnecer más sus fronteras en
general y no solamente la parte que ha
ocupado del territorio ucraniano y abrir
más oportunidades para que la próxima
ofensiva ucraniana encuentre puntos
vulnerables que le permita penetrar las
defensas las defensas rusas
quiero ir con usted y preguntarle algo
que dice Román usted está de acuerdo con
que lo que está ocurriendo en Belgrado
es una prueba de que las fronteras de la
guerra se están extendiendo hacia suelo
ruso
durante todo el año 2022 las fuerzas
ucranianas fueron lo suficientemente
hábiles como para hacer incursiones con
helicópteros con artillería con misiles
hacia la Ciudad de belgorón atacar
puestos de municiones atacar puestos de
combustible todo lo que asistía a la
logística lo original de esta operación
es que es la primera vez que entran
ya sea personal ucraniano según los
rusos o que una milicia rusa cobra la
suficiente el suficiente vigor y fuerza
como para lanzar una operación militar
suicida básicamente porque las
informaciones que están llegando en este
momento es que esa esas funciones esa
operación fracasó Lo que sí es cierto es
que por primera vez
Ucrania se da el lujo de poder pelear
con hombres en territorio Ruso y esto
una una originalidad en los dos años de
en los dos años que van de guerra y esto
es nuevo y obviamente va a poner una
presión adicional en las fuerzas rusas
no tanto porque tenga que replegar
tropas que están en el frente sino
porque acelerará en algún punto el
desplazamiento y el reclutamiento de
nuevos oficiales para ponerlos en la
zona de frontera ustedes coinciden en
algo y es en decir que estos grupos de
mercenarios o de partisanos rusos están
aliados con Ucrania es decir están de
acuerdo en ese sentido con la versión
rusa de que el ejército ucraniano está
respaldando de alguna manera estos
grupos Le quiero preguntar a usted Juan
primero
Por supuesto que sí digamos esto hay que
leerlo en un contexto generalizado de la
guerra como también como muy bien decía
el colega hay que leer que en el 2014
apareció después de la invasión de
crimea aparecieron lo que los americanos
llaman los Little Green men LoL pequeños
hombrecitos verdes a hacer sus sus
tácticas y sus guerras de guerrilla
bueno en este contexto Es lógico que
aparezcan estos hombres y me cuesta
pensar de que pueden ser una facción de
una disidencia rusa pero también
evidentemente hay alguna capacidad
ucraniana involucrada involucrada en ese
aspecto es muy difícil para cualquier
observador Imparcial decir que una una
cosa no está relacionado con con quién
como así también la la insurgencia en
Ucrania no estaba relacionada con Moscú
no Román y Usted qué opina de cómo
explicar que rusos estén atacando
territorio ruso tiene esto algo que ver
con con un descontento que hay en de la
población rusa en contra del kremlin
déjeme precisar un poquito yo creo que
lo que la propaganda rusa está diciendo
es que en realidad los que están
realizando los ataques no son rusos sino
que son ucranianos y en ese sentido yo
creo que la propaganda rusa miente hay
rusos atacando a las tropas rusas
básicamente porque hay un movimiento
creciente De oposición a Putin dentro de
Rusia y yo creo que es importante
también señalar que
estos estos grupos que sin lugar a dudas
cuentan con el apoyo ucraniano porque si
no no pondrían operar en ese sector de
la frontera pero que hay que entender
que son distintos de las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas estos grupos no son
mercenarios son es decir no son
individuos que están siendo pagados para
realizar esto sino que forman parte de
un sector
opositor a Rusia son yo creo que dos
cosas distintas porque si no nos
confundiríamos con el grupo Wagner que
como que como como todos sabemos y los
oyentes saben es un grupo esos Ellos sí
de mercenarios de sujetos contratados
a digamos con el dinero del kremlin para
sostener la guerra en Ucrania y y en
otros en otros muchos sitios verdad
incluido África a Oriente medio etcétera
lo que creo Es que esto es una señal
clara digamos del nivel de
del creciente desgaste digamos por un
lado militar de Rusia en el sentido de
que no tiene la capacidad para
garantizar la totalidad de la seguridad
del frente con Ucrania en la medida en
que ha concentrado sus fuerzas para
defender el territorio que ocupa de
Ucrania pero no las fronteras digamos
legales donde no esperaba ser atacada
por otra parte también del desgaste
político del kremlin verdad de alguna
manera
está empezando a emerger una o alguna de
ellas la mayoría de ellas pacífica Pero
tenemos estos grupos armados que
demuestran digamos que el lugar por
donde está conduciendo
a Putin a Rusia Pues cuenta con un
sector de oposición ruso importante
usted habla de desgaste militar y
desgaste político usted está de acuerdo
Juan con esto sobre todo teniendo en
cuenta que los rusos casi que duplican o
incluso llegan a triplicar la cantidad
de militares ucranianos en en combate y
es esto una muestra de ese desgaste
Es cierto que las fuerzas militares
rusas han recibido
un golpe tras otro que le ha llevado a
desgastar su instrumento militar y que
los ucraneos han sido hábiles Defensores
en términos de la protección de su
territorio Y eso lo ha llevado a
tener las órdenes de movilización a
movilizar 300.000 hombres a sumarlos al
frente de batalla esto es esto es real
el desgaste político es más difícil de
evaluar sobre todo desde
desde afuera de kremlin No si uno si uno
considera que Putin no ha logrado en dos
años éxitos concretos y efectivos porque
más Más allá de que liberó la zona que
él decía que iba a liberar no la
ocupación de Ucrania deja de ser un deja
de poder presentarse como exitosa
Entonces yo diría que sí que hay un
desgaste político y hay un desgaste
militar ahora
lo que no estoy seguro y lo que me
permito ahí tal vez
diferenciarme del colega es que yo tengo
que pensar de que en este momento operan
dos aparatos propagandísticos el Ruso y
el ucraniano y no tengo evidencia de que
esta operación que es apenas a 20 km de
la frontera en Ucrania no sea parte del
aparato
propagandístico ucraniano no entonces
ahí yo creo que tengo me gustaría
manifestar una una diferencia en Pos de
que si hay grupos con la capacidad
suficiente para armarse y presentar
alguna resistencia contra el régimen de
de Vladimir Putin están demasiado lejos
de Moscú y demasiado cerca de la
frontera donde la guerra se pelea creo
sí que es una operación de diversión lo
que se dice de distracción propiamente
dicho de distracción diverso en inglés
distracción en castellano para
eventualmente poder funcionar y llevar
muy bien como decía el colega una una
contraofensiva Pero entonces ustedes no
creen que lo que está ocurriendo en
belgorot pueda cambiar el rumbo de la
guerra en el sentido de que se une a los
ataques que ha habido en territorio ruso
como los drones que atacaron en el
kremlin o el ataque en marzo en brians
que también se lo atribuyó el rbc que es
uno de los grupos o involucrados en
belgradó Le quiero preguntar entonces a
Román Román Usted qué opina puede
cambiar esto el rumbo de la guerra del
hecho de que ya los combates estén en
territorio ruso o simplemente son un
acto de distracción como lo decía Juan
digamos solo solo para para aclarar un
punto hombre Yo creo que hay un sin
lugar a dudas el gobierno ucraniano y
por supuesto el kremlin están utilizando
la propaganda porque es parte de la
guerra pero yo creo que el nivel de
transparencia que tenemos en Ucrania
entre otras cosas porque hay una
multitud de corresponsales occidentales
que pueden Acceder al frente hablar con
tropas hablar con ciudadanos hay
analistas norteamericanos europeos que
han visitado las líneas de frente es muy
infinitamente más grande en Ucrania que
es una democracia que en Rusia que está
transitando de un régimen autoritario a
uno cada vez con visos más totalitarios
dicho esto yo no creo que en sí mismo
esta incursión vaya a cambiar la guerra
es decir creo que es una señal de que
está de que Ucrania está en una fase en
lo que se llama en términos militares
una fase de
de dar forma al campo de batalla donde
se hacen una serie de operaciones de
preparación para al digamos para como
fase previa al lanzamiento de una
ofensiva si ustedes recuerdan con
seguridad que ustedes recuerdan que
hemos visto como ha habido una serie de
ataques en las últimas semanas contra
las líneas de suministro rusas
contra líneas de Comunicaciones
y esto forma parte de esa misma fase que
consiste Por una parte reducir los
recursos que tienen los defensores
dentro de Ucrania y por otra parte
extender la línea de frente que tienen
que cubrir para reducir la capacidad
para defender el frente para tener las
tropas más dispersas y por lo tanto más
vulnerables al ataque ucraniano yo creo
que lo que estamos viendo Ahora sí es el
prólogo de lo que puede ser una ofensiva
que sea decisiva para el curso de la
guerra en el sentido de que de que puede
determinar si Ucrania tiene la capacidad
para recuperar una parte sustantiva del
territorio que Rusia invadió en ese
sentido esta operación no va a cambiar
el curso de la guerra pero sí estamos
justo en el prólogo de una campaña de
una ofensiva que probablemente va a ser
decisiva verdad y cuáles son los riesgos
de esta ofensiva sobre todo teniendo en
cuenta que occidente ha sido reacio
hasta ahora de entregar aviones de
combate y con los misiles de largo
alcance Fue bastante cuidadoso también
porque temía que Ucrania pudiera atacar
a Rusia en territorio Ruso y Rusia
respondiera alargado o prolongando la
guerra y haciéndola aún más grande y a
la otan esto le preocupaba bastante
ahora que estamos viendo ataques en
territorio ruso esto Cómo puede afectar
Esa visión de Moscú de que los
occidentales están apoyando demasiado a
Ucrania y que Ucrania Ya se está
entrando a su propio territorio le
pregunto a Juan
Perdón yo creo que como vos muy bien
decís los Estados Unidos y los aliados
occidentales han tenido cierto cuidado
en el tipo de provisión de armamento que
se dieron en las renovaciones de los
tanques también Ucrania ha sentido El
golpe de una guerra de desgaste no esto
creo que es fundamental señalarlo y de
ahí que Ucrania hoy pelea gracias
armamento y al apoyo financiero y
económico que que recibe de occidente
sumado al coraje de los soldados
ucranianos que eso está fuera de
discusión la pregunta clave es esta es
cómo está cómo Rusia va a interpretar
estas acciones y si está dispuesto a
escalar el conflicto lo que es
importante de la contraofensiva es si
Ucrania es capaz de Recuperar el casi el
10 el 15% del territorio que todavía
está en control de los de los rusos
muchos esperan que la contraofensiva
sirva para eso y que eso al mismo tiempo
dispare frente a un eventual catástrofe
en el plano militar que enfrente las
fuerzas rusas que bueno
echada a la suerte Rusia intente alguna
especie de escalada un poco más
más grande o con otro con un
involucramiento militar diferente al que
hemos visto ahora y considerando de ha
atacado a través de aire por mar y por
por con misiles superficies superficies
Prácticamente todo Ucrania qué le queda
a Rusia escalar y ahí la clave y el
cuidado que ha tenido occidente muy bien
y también los analistas occidentales en
En declamar qué operaciones son apoyadas
por occidente o por lo tanto justamente
para no darle la excusa a Putin para que
para que escale no yo digo que una una
imagen de la guerra es t-72 contra t72
t72 ucranianos contra t-72 es rusos van
a van a combatir y es una imagen que es
indistinta para cualquier analista o
para cualquier persona que está mirando
la guerra ahora cuando uno ve combatir
un tanque ruso con un t-72 y un leo para
alemán ya ahí la imagen Es muy poderosa
puede cambiar y eso puede llevar a un
empeoramiento de la situación Román y si
a esa balanza que nos Pro le agregamos
rusos combatiendo del lado del ejército
ucraniano Cuál es el resultado final El
problema es que Rusia no tiene buenas
opciones en este momento es decir a
movilizó aproximadamente se calcula unos
300.000 soldados
que han cuadrado con mucha dificultad no
tiene suficientes oficiales o
suboficiales para encuadrar los ha
entrenado mal y los ha equipado peor con
eso
está tratando de mantener la defensa del
territorio que que que que que ocupa
dentro de Ucrania es muy difícil pensar
que en el corto plazo va a poder
realizar otra movilización no tanto
porque no tenga población para movilizar
que la tiene más que de sobra sino
porque tiene una capacidad muy limitada
para encuadrar entrenar y armar a estas
tropas En consecuencia está jugando
Rusia con lo que tiene la posibilidad de
una escalada es digamos de una escalada
más de lo que ha escalado Rusia quiero
decir porque Rusia ha utilizado todo lo
que a su disposición salvo armas
nucleares que es muy improbable que
llegue a usar entre otras cosas porque
eso supondría el final de respaldo chino
para Rusia y en consecuencia digamos
probablemente colocaría en una posición
muy muy difícil al régimen al régimen de
Putin y al propio Vladimir Putin que
probablemente inmediatamente después
perdería el poder verdad En consecuencia
Me parece que lo que vamos a ver ahora
es si Ucrania tiene la capacidad para
ocupar una parte sustantiva de de para
recuperar una parte sustantiva del
territorio que ocupa que ocupa Rusia Me
parece que vamos a tener un resultado
digamos un tanto digamos parcial es muy
probable que Ucrania ocupe un recupere
una parte sustantiva de del territorio
que ocupa Rusia pero no la totalidad del
mismo y por otra parte es muy probable
también que Rusia lo Que decida es
continuar prolongando la guerra aunque
sea unas condiciones militares cada vez
más difíciles para ella Simplemente
porque no puede aceptar Putin no puede
aceptar que es que que está siendo
Derrotado y y Él espera que el tiempo
juegue a su favor Les propongo que ahora
miremos del lado ucraniano quienes están
detrás de la región libertad de Rusia y
del cuerpo de voluntarios rusos porque
por parte de la legión está por ejemplo
el líder político es hilvanomarévez que
es un antiguo diputado ruso expulsado
precisamente por oponerse al kremlin y
del lado de rbc está Denis nikiti quien
al final Times afirmó que Ucrania los
había respaldado en la incursión en
brians que es una región muy cerca de
belgorot en Rusia y que fue atacada en
marzo y fue el primer ataque la primera
incursión por tierra Quiénes son estos
dos personajes Y quién financia estas
legiones
le preguntó a Juan
estos estos personajes claramente son el
rostro visible de lo que de lo que
estamos discutiendo acá que son unas son
protos proto insurgencias como toda
guerra y de vuelta y que coincidiendo
con el con el colega Con Román acerca de
los aparatos propagandísticos y las
diferencias que tiene un régimen
democrático un régimen autocrático son
actores secundarios y marginales en esta
guerra no vuelvo a este punto yo creo
que no van a poder cambiar el curso de
la guerra si son útiles A quién en tanto
en cuanto le abren un frente donde Rusia
se sentía no quiero decir seguro pero
bueno difícilmente uno pudiera pensar en
una penetración terrestre por parte de
fuerzas ucranianas o de fuerzas
disidentes ahora
el aparato propagandístico de kiev tiene
las imágenes que ustedes están mostrando
en este momento lograron penetrar por
otro lado el aparato propagandístico de
de
Moscú Ha logrado Mostrar que muchos de
estos hombres ya están Muertos o el
equipamiento está destruido Quiénes lo
financian difícil saberlo seguramente
hay recursos que se destinan para
financiar estas estas unidades estas
insurgencias muchas veces estas
insurgencias También tienen vínculos
criminales
recordemos solamente para decir lo que
muchos de estos hombres que plantearon
una especie de guerra civil en Ucrania
después terminaron financiándose con
dineros criminales no entonces difícil
saberlo ahora cierto es que han generado
un evento más en esta guerra Trágica
para rusos y para ucranes para
ucranianos y para Juan usted dice que el
impacto militar de esta clase de grupos
rusos asociados a los ucranianos es
marginal Y menciona un aspecto de la
guerra y es esta guerra informática la
guerra de la propaganda que claramente
de tanto Ucrania como Rusia han
desplegado Román en ese sentido esta
clase de grupos pueden tener alguna
afectación contra la imagen del kremlin
y favorecer a kiev
hombre lo que está claro es que lo que
demuestra es muy muy interesante que
estamos hablando como si la penetración
hubiese sido hecha por Ucrania pero lo
cierto es que los que se presentan son
rusos en consecuencia Eso hace que
digamos se cuestionen dos cuestiones que
de alguna manera son críticas para la
credibilidad de Vladimir Putin primero
la capacidad para mantener la seguridad
del territorio ruso que está en cuestión
en la medida en que estos grupos que
estamos de acuerdo que son pequeños y
que tienen unas capacidades limitadas
sin embargo han sido capaces de de
vulnerar Por otra parte la existencia de
una oposición digamos Insisto que estos
grupos armados son minoritarios pero
está claro que tienen bastante que ver
con sectores más amplios de las de la
sociedad rusa que no están de acuerdo
con lo que está con lo que está pasando
Ah quiere decir esto que el régimen de
Putin está cercano a colapsar
Lo cierto es que no es decir Putin
todavía tiene unas herramientas de poder
importantes en sus manos Pero lo que sí
es verdad es que estos estas grietas que
aparecen reducen el margen de maniobra
de Vladimir Putin para hacer ciertas
cosas digamos por ejemplo para escala
para aumentar la movilización que es
algo muy impopular por ejemplo entonces
a digamos no son un factor decisivo pero
sí son un factor significativo verdad
ustedes son de acuerdo con este
planteamiento Juan de que estos grupos
abren unas grietas que aunque no son
profundas reducen el margen de maniobra
de Putin sobre todo al momento de
reclutar rusos para enviarlos al frente
de combate
Cuando comenzó la orden de movilización
General aparecieron resistencias en en
gran parte de la sociedad de Rusia y al
punto tal de que muchos decidieron huir
irse de Rusia recordemos que eso generó
alguna presión en las fronteras propias
europeas
inclusive Argentina recibió ciudadanos
rusos que se escapaban entre otras
cuestiones de estas órdenes de
movilización eso es cierto hay
resistencia pero en general y las
últimas
encuestas hechas por occidentales eh por
por ipsos por ejemplo demuestran que en
general el público de Rusia en un 65% de
la encuestada apoya todavía el esfuerzo
de guerra y que perciben justamente por
la eficiencia no por la credibilidad
externa sino por la credibilidad interna
y por la eficiencia que tiene
comunicacional el gobierno
de Putin son sienten y han comprado el
discurso de que estos son amenazados por
por occidente no Entonces
coincido con el con el argumento que se
está que se está señalando pero hay que
reconocer que todavía Rusia tiene
músculo músculo militar y músculo
propagandístico a su favor Juan muy
brevemente una contra pregunta para
usted cree que esta voluntad de los
rusos de apoyar al kremlin y la
favorabilidad que ha tenido Putin puede
haberse afectada con ataques ahora los
rusos viéndolos dentro de su propio país
como como externo como extranjero
desearía que sí porque esta guerra es
brutal por otro lado objetivamente y con
las evidencias que tengo tengo que decir
que no que no no me parece Porque Rusia
está ha recibido ataques desde Ucrania
desde desde la segunda mitad del dos en
adelante
Ucrania fue hábil y logró atacar como
decía al principio
determinadas posiciones en territorio en
territorio Ruso y eso acrecentó el apoyo
de los de los rusos al kremlin no porque
porque cuando la guerra se peleó en la
tierra de uno no se siente mucho más
comprometido no entonces Me permito
señalar eso Romario usted quería también
responder no no yo creo que digamos hay
una hay una serie de digamos el es
cierto lo que comentaba muy mi colega en
el sentido de que todavía Vladimir Putin
cuenta con un respaldo digamos Popular
de acuerdo con las significativo pero
eso es eso es sostenible tanto tiempo
como la guerra no afecte cada vez más y
más a la vida cotidiana de los rusos es
interesante señalar por ejemplo el uso
que ha tenido que hacer el kremlin de
manera sistemática y masiva de
mercenarios y de mercenarios reclutados
en las prisiones como una manera de
minimizar o de tratar de reducir digamos
todo lo que se pueda Las bajas que
sufren los ciudadanos digamos comunes de
rusos verdad Entonces
hay hay Pero pero sobre todo Me parece
que la clave sobre donde donde puede
digamos descansar a la interrogante
sobre Cuánto cuánto espacio político le
queda Putin Es sobre todo sobre el
respaldo que puede contar con los
líderes regionales rusos es decir el
kremling Depende para mantener el
control del territorio del control
político de Rusia de una serie de
líderes canales que gobiernan sus
regiones y que son Realmente los que le
están digamos sosteniendo el país a
Vladimir Putin si las si el respaldo de
esta de este grupo se debilita la
viabilidad del régimen se podría haber
comprometida seriamente así como Putin
necesita el respaldo de los gobernadores
regionales Ucrania necesita el respaldo
de occidente Romano muy brevemente Le
quiero preguntar si este respaldo puede
cambiar teniendo en cuenta que cada vez
aumentan los ataques en territorio rusos
y bien Juan nos estaba diciendo que la
ofensiva ucraniana en Rusia se comenzó
de segunda mitad del 2022 ya hemos visto
mayores ataques en brians cerca de Moscú
ahora en belgorot Esto puede cambiar el
panorama Y hacer que occidente deje de
respaldar tan abiertamente Ucrania o no
No definitivamente yo creo que estos
ataques entran dentro de lo que resulta
de que vamos perfectamente aceptable
lógico dentro de una confrontación en la
medida que no estamos hablando de
ataques contra digamos zonas urbanas o
muy dentro del territorio ruso sino
cerca de la línea de frente cerca de la
línea de contacto verdad dicho esto Me
parece que el apoyo occidental está está
garantizado en el corto plazo Me parece
que la gran interrogante que deberíamos
de pensar es qué podría pasar si en las
elecciones de 2024
llega como candidato republicano el
presidente el ex presidente Donald Trump
y gana las elecciones después de que
haya expresado que no estaría digamos
dispuesto a continuar con la misma
política de respaldo hacia Ucrania Pero
de aquí al 2024 Me parece que el
respaldo para Ucrania está garantizado
por los países occidentales Juan usted
coincide con esto que el respaldo de
occidente está garantizado
coincido Y lo demuestra básicamente que
Estados Unidos le dio a Ucrania desde el
inicio de la guerra hasta este momento
cerca de 80 mil millones de dólares
Europa le ha dado en su conjunto veinte
mil millones de dólares entre municiones
asistencia humanitaria o sea el el apoyo
está garantizado siempre y cuando
Ucrania mantenga la mantenga la guerra
en una guerra defensiva Aunque eso
implique cada tanto tener que golpear
parte del territorio
ruso Yo lo único que agregaría ahí es
que no solamente es una cuestión de
Donald Trump habría que prestar atención
también a otros candidatos republicanos
que también se han manifestado en contra
de seguir apoyando tan activamente y con
tantos dólares a Ucrania como ha sido el
candidato ron de santis y hay una
discusión adentro de
Estados Unidos en relación a
continuación de ese apoyo y ya para
cerrar nuestro programa Juan Le quiero
preguntar cuál es su conclusión de cómo
entender este ataque en belgorot
respecto a la guerra
como una como un preludio como una
operación de distracción a lo que puede
ser una una ofensiva más importante más
centralizada para lograr el objetivo
militar que es correr a las tropas rusas
del territorio ucraniano
en primer lugar en segundo lugar como
algo para levantar la moral no para para
decir seguimos seguimos peleando por qué
digo es más probable que sean ucranianos
que no sean ucranianos porque la moral
en guerra también es un factor que
importa mucho y demostrar al mundo sin
decirlo abiertamente pero Mostrar al
mundo que no tiene la capacidad de
golpear la retaguardia del enemigo
siempre siempre es importante me hace
acordar a la a la operación
norteamericana que cuando cuatro aviones
re-24 despegaron de un portaaviones y
atacaron Tokio de Al poco tiempo de Park
Harbor esto es importante del punto de
vista de la moral y si después son
disidencias rusas o cómo operan creo que
secundario pero no deja de ser un dato
tampoco creo que vaya a ser un factor
que genere un cambio
tremendo en la guerra o que sea un
factor decisivo para que Rusia se sienta
a negociar pero sí es importante en en
estos momentos donde a veces parece que
ucraniana Ucrania como David está
peleando como un Goliat tremendo no Y
entonces Eso es bueno Y ante este David
y Goliat entonces belgorot vendría a
levantar la moral de las tropas
ucranianas como usted lo dice y además
como un preludio de La contraofensiva
Romana Cuál es su conclusión
yo creo que estamos efectivamente
digamos muy cerca de ver digamos de un
momento decisivo en la guerra y que va a
ser esta contraofensiva
a ucraniana y me parece que
probablemente eso va a determinar
sobre todo digamos las condiciones sobre
los las cuales digamos se va a digamos
yo creo que se va a prolongar la guerra
pero sin lugar a dudas también digamos
va a poner en cuestión o va a dar
credibilidad a la política occidental la
va a hacer más sostenible si Ucrania
tiene éxito y va a hacer la posición de
Vladimir Putin más frágil y más débil
entonces me parece que estamos justo al
comienzo este este ataque es de alguna
manera la campanada de salida para lo
que puede ser la ofensiva ucraniana que
desde luego se va a mover dentro del
territorio ocupado por Ucrania pero que
va a estar acompañado por estas acciones
digamos
en la periferia para tratar de diluir la
defensa rusa y una ofensiva que aquí en
el debate y en Francia 24 analizaremos
Román Ortiz y Juan bataleme gracias por
acompañarnos en el debate y a ustedes
nuestra audiencia les agradezco también
su sintonía en nombre de nuestro equipo
técnico la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Luis Fernando Montes y
la de los invitados la tuvo Tania
Herrera ustedes sigan dejando todos sus
comentarios en redes sociales y
continúen con nosotros aquí en France 24
[Música]